no hey what's happening thanks for
turning into another letter B talk it is
the [ __ ] in sessions this episode is
brought to you by my fantastic
motorcycle sponsor el cajon Harley and
just a heads up Elko and Harley is going
to be the only dealer in California to
have the first 2017 Harley demo feet so
you can go down there September I think
its third and fourth and ride the brand
new bikes I'm dying to see what they got
you never know they keep it a secret but
I'm hearing new motor I'm here in
Milwaukee Milwaukee's ate some kind of
new motor 107 engine will see they
they're going to have it then I'm going
to go down and write it meet me down
there barbecue and party check it out el
cajon Harley also el cajon Harley's
taking me to see guns and roses on
thursday at the Dodger Stadium Thank You
El Cajon Harley do we know who the
special guest is yet there's a roll it
okay yeah yeah that's all that's awesome
they announced it today that cold
everybody say could say CDC yeah yeah
that would be crazy it might be I feel
that way you never know yeah I mean you
know um I'm pray in that Adler place cuz
I you know he did too funky states like
Cincinnati and something else i think it
was like Nashville I'm not funky but you
know just so I know where he lives yeah
not san fran not la not during not even
Seattle you know and and it kind of
seems like a genius move if they just
came out with Izzy and [ __ ] oh the
[ __ ] dodger stadium would melt down
man imagine like that's the next super
group is like after this gnr tour yeah
after axel goes out I guess no he
already did the yeah you're they CDs do
ten more days or whatever um and at the
end they're just like you know what
let's just become a AC a G C and D arcy
like that's the van I think what's gonna
happen is they're gonna do this whole
run and then for like a year or so and
then they'll go oh hey we got the other
two guys back another stadium
you know what I mean this is like cuz
that'll be like well I got to see that
now you know what I mean and no one will
be like that's [ __ ] i would just be
like oh I'm there too you know well I
think that's the beauty and I mean this
sincerely of like what the dead have
done right they did I did not the dead
someone eles like we are the dead but we
houses for the filling in yeah and now
we're not it out again but like a girl
in a year or two they get someone
awesome to come in and play with them
and it's it's it's a smart way to keep
your fans involved what I want as you
tweet about the topic is getting old
yeah as an old guy or an old getting
older guy but I'm comfortable with could
you imagine how badass Las Vegas would
be if AC DC in gnr did a residency in
Vegas like I love I'm okay with pop like
I love Britney Spears I'll listen to
Justin be Rick it's fine i listen to
everything yeah but like a britney
spears residency in vegas is totally
different didn't [ __ ] gnr had a
residency it's just a dancing residency
yeah yeah a show premiere or did your
residency but with the with the like the
weird line up the icon the oh right well
that's what what was that called what
are they called the Macho Man guys well
I think when they come watch my uh what
are they college people yeah yeah that's
kind of what the gnr was they had been
here's our / looking guy and we've got
an easy looking guy and then we've got a
guy that does a bucket on his head young
checks and and they kind of covered
every step again we got an industrial
rocker here's the pink ranger
but they did a residency at the Hard
Rock twice and it was super [ __ ]
successful yeah imagine it with the
other guys it would just be I think
residency's uh I keep thinking the
stones she do want you know at Vegas
like cuz they then they don't need to
tour they just you come to us right you
were gonna be here it's gonna be an
awesome [ __ ] experience we're getting
older we don't need to be on a [ __ ]
bus or on a plane or whatever every two
days and exams in here you can get the
sound completely down cuz you're there
for like six weeks out yeah I remember
what's his name Garth Brooks did one
okay and I think he's still kind of
doing it but a Steve Wynn I believe he
had written he hadn't played in like 10
years or something see when today I want
you to do a residency here and he's like
nah so well how about this is like mad
wait how about this and this yeah
because that looks good but I need
private jet to because I need to be home
on Monday to take my kids to school so
he would be private jets in I guess
there's like thursday friday saturday
sunday flies on sunday night and then he
takes his kids to school crazy paper
probably more rested than i am just
driving home from here oh yeah exactly
zero traffic at his sky just up and down
the best residency i think a non vegas
residency and your knowledge of this is
larger than mine but whatever was two or
three years ago when Prince did his
residency in la at Lex night i love
residency's on the tape fan if you're an
awesome band do a residency and it's
just great because they get like the set
this is like their set list or whatever
but then after like the 3rd night
they're gonna be different or worse
boiled in LA and I think New York is
like this to where it's like yeah I'm
doing a residency and I'm Prince oh by
the way here's John Mayer oh by the way
here's Elton John oh by the way have
jewel I don't know why jewels here yeah
I don't you or whatever it is yeah
kinds of killers showing up yeah like
sting and stuff and then they play crazy
songs like what and then you get in the
parking lot afterwards and ride a bike
around yeah four more hours singing and
then on his off nights from the
residency here Prince did four shows for
like ten dollars at the troubadour
unbelievable just stuff like that is
cool and could you imagine the stories
that would come out of a gnr Vegas
residency oh man and be awesome so great
man so yeah I'm going on Thursday what
about that band you out blink-182
they're doing like a la residency it's
like four or five nights sold out they
kept adding date I know I got tickets to
october first and i might if anyone can
lock this down i might be like have like
nice guest like really doing it access
um I'm so excited cuz it when they were
first announced it it was the last show
of the tour right in LA and I pulled
some strings to make that happen to get
those like I got those before you could
get those and then like they keep adding
date and now they're doing one like four
days ina may be the last show yeah I
gotta go to that one else I saw the
billboard on sunset they got one by The
Comedy Store and it just has the dates
or slashes but that billboard I can
understand because they put that
billboard up before it was sold out what
I don't understand is the new billboard
here in LA I think it's on santa monica
and its new they put it maybe last week
and it's Adele yeah I saw April center
yeah like seven dates sold out like why
do you put up that you already bad boys
share anything like like that you need
to promoting it's already sold out it's
just like Adele this billboard is a
heated I bet it should say a doubt you
[ __ ] slept and didn't get tickets
yeah I mean oh my god I saw they asked
her to play the Super Bowl and she said
no pretty cool yeah it's funny because
of course the word on the street was if
you wanted to play the Super Bowl you
had to pee like a million dollars over
the last couple years that was like a
new thing nothing makes me want to watch
guys crackheads then sad girl songs why
you're joking but that's the point of
that is to get your girl exterior
typical girlfriend to also watch the
Super Bowl yeah everyone wants to see
the guys are watching the loom and then
the girl it's a genius move to get the
women to watch it also even if they're
like single and they wouldn't watch the
Super Bowl yeah
but you know somebody put in a great a
great thing today it was like some I
don't Reba McEntire someone was leaving
the airport and TMZ caught him and said
hey who do you think should play the
Super Bowl and she said I think it's
time for country to come back and I
don't really listen to that much country
but I agree with that too most of
America would lose their mind and
there's been no real country that is
just rock rock rock or hip-hop or you
know imagine i'm picturing now because
he has a new album coming out and
because if you're saying Garth is doing
a residency kind of Garth came on stage
and then part way through Bruce came on
stage oh and it's just like America head
experts for America like bald eagles fly
over USA Football Bruce and Garth yeah
it's just incredible yeah well they
never played together I pressure to look
that up I have no idea that's [ __ ]
show though that's insane and then and
then Billy Joel just comes out in the
piano office because just because yeah
yeah ability Joxer it's funny you say
Springsteen cuz i was thinkin the topic
today is getting old i was getting out
of bed today and i was just I'm just
[ __ ] man yeah like I get up how old
are you 35 I mean 21 yeah I'm 50 and I
get up and I'm just like I feel like
that Louis CK bit about his ankle I just
get up and things just don't work it's
like first the back of my heel the left
foot the back part of the heel is always
like oh [ __ ] what's going on it just
[ __ ] hurts that part only that part
I've been going through different shoes
for the last two months seems to be
worse when I wear these super
comfortable Doc Martens maybe they're
too soft huh I have no ideas are like
[ __ ] oh yeah and then and then it goes
up into my neck still and then I started
trippin I was in New York for two weeks
neck didn't hurt at all so now I'm
thinking okay it's definitely got to be
the motorcycle or the helmet yeah so
your next back hurting a little bit here
and there Mike okay it's got to be the
motorcycle I went out for two weeks it's
hard to do
those variables I wonder if it's and you
think you have a very nice bed if I
recall yeah that's a good bed that is it
your your desk a pillow like the way you
normal you know the way you normally
work to podcast like you have an awesome
chair and a great setup but it's like
not quite right so your your alignments
just a little off yeah it's gotta be
something out of the three now since
I've been it i was in new york and
everything was fine i mean i was i was
actually running around New York I'll
[ __ ] him back to normal I got couldn't I
was running up the subway stairs like
yeah you know and I was side kicks about
a boy yeah in a city it's like Dean
because doing that ck where he runs up
the thing I'm like yeah I'm [ __ ] in
shape and I'm get in shape I'm going to
the gym and [ __ ] but uh you know so
then I'm like okay it's bed pillow
helmet or motorcycle I can't [ __ ]
figure it out yeah and then there I am
today running down the rabbit hole am I
gonna have to [ __ ] start driving
again you know to mean and then I
started thinking how the [ __ ] do you get
old like 60 and 70 oh I mean cuz I'm not
like out of shape I [ __ ] I'm yeah
we're not before I even worked out I you
know I [ __ ] hike everything and now
I'm just like you know you see those old
people with a hunched over you know like
Big Ten I feel like that right now yeah
what I think I think that's the hard
part of being a not to be too nerdy but
like a carbon-based life form like we
don't just die like some of us do we
just died yeah but the act of our
existence is decomposing like we are
wearing out yeah and so everything
breaks down like I could maybe this
let's see if this gets on uh-uh van all
that noise yeah crash all the time my
ankles my knees and it's like not pain
yet but I know it didn't used to be like
that I was had a like a pre-production
meeting for this thing yesterday I'm
sitting there with like people that know
me but the same time were you trying to
be a good behavior and we just like a
long meeting I've had to stand up and
walk around because my feet were lights
out of sleep just cuz my circulation is
[ __ ] now and I like
I'm sorry I need to stand up and I don't
like you're boring the [ __ ] at this is
awful yeah yeah but like we are
everything wears down its you know you
look at a car and how often those joints
are being used and how often are you
moving your elbow so little they were
putting new [ __ ] in there no joke yes
it's it's crazy knowing like and then if
I wear too thick a denim my knees
[ __ ] hurt because the denim is too
thick on my knee you know like
everything around its bro my mother i
was looking at new balance and II you
know but and I've been going through the
last couple weeks of like okay I gotta
get like a boot or something a nice boot
that's like my boots all feel too heavy
everything around like I'm just it just
all happened too and I don't know if
it's like repercussions get on the crash
like I'm still [ __ ] up you know Mark
Cuban swears by skechers Oh try dad you
tried some scattered what we need is
like we need like second elbows and
second knees because it's ridiculous to
think that the thing that works when
you're ten is supposed to still work
when you're 50 right what happens is
when you turn forty eight like this
elbow fuses yeah and then the new one
goes to church and unlocks nearly yeah
like a snake or whatever you know looser
like this one's done up done with that
one hears an elbow to every tenure is
painful for like two day Nick number
nine yuck it's [ __ ] crazy though and
then you know like I'm at the gym and
I'm stretching and everything and then
that hurts right now I've got this inner
thigh was like oh no I got a hernia you
know to me but it was just like
stretching and and then you talk to you
doctor though you might have pulled
something that'll be about three weeks
like three weeks when I pick up the bike
right now I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah it's
insane well that's the hardest part to
so people that don't know my wife is a
physician she's an internist which is
essentially primary care he is a only
works with adults but if you go to the
doctor you people say oh family practice
and that's probably an internist
whatever yeah but the heart mean the
thing about that is you know she this
isn't a specific patient of hers just
anecdotal over
years you know people come in it's like
oh my neck hurt sir why does it hurt
when I do this stop doing don't do that
like there's nothing like yeah yeah our
bodies kind of suck yeah like my left
knee hurts I can't run as much as I want
to there's nothing to do about it it's
crazy it's just a nation then I travel
now all the time right and and then I'm
just [ __ ] so now I'm going online i'm
looking up every [ __ ] reward things
maybe i might go right I gotta get there
before I just blow the miles off its
like you find the cheapest ticket but
now maybe pay ten dollars more to always
fly south way yeah yeah exactly because
now I need to start getting bumped up to
some business and because here's what
happened to me yesterday I was firing
home from Salt Lake and I'm how was that
[ __ ] great a great comedy scene right
what I mean me oh yeah you're out there
that's right yeah first of all the guy
that owns the club keith is unbelievably
cool it was two of them Keith and I
didn't meet the other one it was just
key was he at him I'm pressed by wrong
but yeah the room was beautiful and you
downtown yeah and it was packed I mean
pack dear Sunday night everybody's
telling me a Sunday you tell everything
is closed no one goes out you know
Mormon land you're gonna be you're gonna
be doing comedy to no one and I was like
well yeah understand I just need to get
out there and run my hour yo no cuz I
hadn't ran the hour and over six weeks
cuz I was out with allysin chaynes doing
20 yeah I'm then I was in New York and
you're only doing 15 s everywhere on
20's everywhere yeah and after a while
if you don't run your our it it gets um
it gets clunky right because in your
mind you're gone okay where do I go from
here hows it and I try to do it organic
and dangerous I just go up and go ahead
i know the bits let's start this and
that can get [ __ ] scary yeah cuz
you're like did i do this bit where am i
am lost well you had one of those and
please no I'm you know this but Troy
listen I'm not talking [ __ ] about Dean
but this is when we were in Arizona yeah
who did like whatever was 7h whoever us
for whatever it was and in the middle of
was I think maybe our thursday or friday
and that middle
show you started a bit and you're like
guys say this yeah and you had that
moment we've all had it I feel like yeah
but it was the first time that was the
first time I realized that you are
mortal you know I got Guillen goes up an
earned his material yeah you just
finished along so I think you like we're
an eight and then got back you know
shows that time between shows disappears
yeah and you start it into a thing you
had fun you went off on an audience
tangent then you kind of got back into
your rhythm he started a bit again and
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah good if you're
not [ __ ] and also I don't do any
order right yeah because I can't stand
going in order i realize last year when
i was out on the road headlining you get
into an order and then you get
mechanical yeah and you get [ __ ] i
mean just boredom you're like I go from
this bit to that bid to that bit then
feels like there's no soul and some guys
can pull up some guys can tell her about
yeah I just can't because I think when
you know there's people like like us
they are a lot of our friends that go on
like all the time yeah if you go on all
the time and do the same order you will
have no feeling at all yeah and then the
audience can pick up on that you're just
like a deliberate like and then I said
blah blah blah you know and I think some
of it is from our different but similar
backgrounds were like in music yeah
you're playing the same songs or the set
list but every night's not the same
thing you have a different guitar so you
gotta say list on the ground right
you're working at what's next right I
mean here you're like you know but you
get to put you have fun in the song it's
all the same totally you get to have fun
in that moment and you know that your
drummer is gonna get carry you yeah not
just be like nah dude this is what are
you doing hey you did a pre chorus twice
yeah it's not gonna work out and like
when I skated like you have your line
but the art of the fun of it is the fill
basically I'm in brookfield the space
last year after I saw the dead yeah I
was like that I'm gonna be like today
I'm just gonna my sets are gonna be jams
yeah and I did it for about six months
and then after about six months Isaac
all right I gotta read
and cuz I was like I would be ripping
and material then [ __ ] you know no
order John Mayer takes the stage it was
really it was fun though it was
dangerous and crazy but you know now I'm
trying to I want to wrangle it down and
figure out the what's good and also
another bummer for me lately as I go on
so much that the material gets old to me
quick I couldn't imagine being a comic
in the 90s where no one saw your
material and you just did it for years
that's bizarre because to me it's just
like I'm like I need to meet comedies
about working new [ __ ] until this is
working and even my steps only like four
to six months old right now it feels
like three years old yeah i was looking
it up in the book that moving shits only
since i moved yeah I moved in January
yeah you know and in Vienna it's just
fun and then you'll do a bit that's a
year old you but this so [ __ ] old huh
oh yeah you all those guys we love they
work [ __ ] for a solid year year and
heaven and shoot it you know yeah so you
just got to get over that and I think
that's something to be in a new comedian
learn how to get over that and and treat
it like these are my songs my [ __ ]
you know my gold yeah I'm gonna go out
and work I'm you know cuz it takes it's
a lot a lot of work to write [ __ ] right
so don't just toss it away especially if
it's killing right it's [ __ ] crazy
anyway so you're saying to come back
from Salt Lake Salt Lake yeah in Salt
Lake was great but I supposed to be on
the UH I always far as southwest if it's
cheap or whatever and then this time I
flew united which is pretty good but uh
the flight well I [ __ ] up on my flight
and they they move me to delta which is
I didn't even know you could do I guess
it's the same owners your son I don't
know we're all [ __ ] yeah next thing
you know I'm on Delta the seats are I'm
like actual way bigger and real with a
screen
brand new screen like virgin a film on
virgin from New York yeah awesome
JetBlue but everyone just bought virgin
so today yeah Virginia's not virgin
anymore well it's not yeah I just flew
with him yeah and it hasn't happened but
they're not independently owned Wow
[ __ ] uh Richard Branson doesn't own
it wow I look it up good anyway so I get
on Oh these seats are way better yeah
and now i'm thinking like i don't know i
need to spend a little more money beyond
some exit row always you know so i got
some [ __ ] leg room yeah and and and a
better you know southwest is great for
one hour to san fran right Oh Arizona or
something but once you get into the two
three four hours man you know I need
some [ __ ] my ass dies in a seat yeah
it dies yeah Alaska Air bought them oh
they did I just there I've had good
experiences with them too oh yeah scared
too so but that's one thing but yeah
like Oh what it's a luxury to be able to
fly in the sky and get to New York and
six hours or whatever is like that again
it's the it's mind blowing I wish it was
better but it's mind-blowing but it is a
type of thing where you know
statistically if you look at it I
understand the arguments that air travel
is more accessible and more affordable
today than it ever was totally but it
still just sucks to feel like everything
is nickel and diming you every [ __ ]
way like okay I go I'm waiting for the
day where it's like all you get is the
middle seat yeah you want a window it's
two dollars more if you want an aisle
it's four dots like that right one thing
it's this if you bring a bag it's this
if you do this it's this if your dick is
six inches long or longer yeah you're
gonna need to pay more if it's two
inches or while you're gonna pay more
you're just takes too heavy for the
[ __ ] front it's like that there are
those blind seats on United yeah they're
like these four rows are more expensive
than these their economy plus or
whatever [ __ ] then the exit rows $31
more yeah so if at first when I'm
booking the flight ago look at this man
killer oh yeah 300 round trip and then
you get into and you go I'm Anna being
may bring it back yeah you bring a bag
another 50 you know whatever it's it's
it's a it's insane it's just not a good
experience yeah whatever the price needs
to be like I think there's something to
be said about customer experience and
making you feel like you're not getting
ripped off like I own a lot of apple
products and there's the Apple tax like
you could maybe build a comparable or
more powerful pc for cheaper but and
this is my bias but in my opinion they
make that experience worth it I don't go
to the apple store and feel like they're
ripping me off along the way i know i'm
paying more but i feel like i'm getting
what i'm paying for first of all other
metal right now instead of [ __ ]
brittle plastic they [ __ ] work
forever they don't crash you know get
viruses or whatever you know I mean I
still have bad dreams over my thinkpad
yeah yeah it was [ __ ] frozen you know
or you look at the you know the dark
years of Harley I'd whatever that was ms
70 s alright whenever it happened and
like they learned their lesson yeah and
it's like it's expensive bike you can
get a cheaper bike than a Harley ok own
get a bike that even looks kind of like
a Harley well for half the price of a
Harley but hardly learned their lesson
and they know what they're selling you
when you go in the dealerships holy [ __ ]
I mean it's an experience yeah and like
Porsche is the same way for cars like
hang more you can get a really dope
Volkswagen like you can get or whatever
but I ain't get [ __ ] hour they make
you feel good about what you're doing
airlines are just like you how you
[ __ ] idiot you [ __ ] it and then they
kick you and spit on you they don't give
a photo I gotta tell you though the guy
that helped me at United that got me on
Delta truck yet because I made a major
rookie move yeah and booked my return
flight 8am get there it's a p.m. uh-huh
what happens when you [ __ ] doing
everything yourself i love when people
hit me up there like your podcast really
should be out every yeah monday morning
at five in it's like hey I'm one-man
show I don't got a producer I don't got
an edit
I don't have a guy chasing down the
guess if there's an audio engineer out
there that wants to work on one of the
best podcast I don't you can email Dean
at Dean Del Rey yahood I don't know what
it is something like that yeah it's
[ __ ] you know so here i am in between
you know editing a podcast oh [ __ ] i
didn't book my flight for [ __ ] sunday
i gotta get that now yeah it's uh and
it's you know it's [ __ ] [ __ ] to
complain about that stuff and I could
plan it but it's like my body is falling
apart man and I'm doing good [ __ ] I'm
stretching everything god I'm like I'll
tell you in the last two weeks I've
tried on about 70 pairs of boots Yeah
Yeah right cuz I'm just like like Doc
Martens it's my favorite cuz they you
know they they just disintegrate you get
another pair and just [ __ ] keep
wearing them they're great yeah but when
i wear my left [ __ ] heel is just
torqued i don't know what it is and I
don't want a leave or advil to be right
in my [ __ ] belly every day ya know
but right now it's the way I move around
yeah when I was running in college I was
on I forget what it was a lot I'll say a
number where does too much know it was
like 16 or 30 at bill a day like double
digit that's horrible for I was really
bad for me I did it for maybe two two
seasons Wow like I can't so that's why I
don't I got out and I had some you know
chance to maybe make like a move it
running professionally I was just like
my body was like you're not gonna do it
they're not gonna don't don't you it's
not worth it yeah you know I just think
about like everything's going good and
if I could just like my here's the thing
I wouldn't even mind cruising around
America in a like a Prius doing comedy
yeah anyway I've never had an airport of
something I i traveled to salt lake with
zero anything no bags enough that's
unbelievable feels like I don't have
anything but a phone charger and a
toothbrush yeah you know what I mean I
don't give a [ __ ] and that's how I like
to travel because I can't stand yeah I
carry a bag then my back hurts yeah I'm
just old
beat up from that crash I realized that
crash [ __ ] me up way more than I thought
what side did you go down on well I hit
this side yeah and then rolled onto my
back and just slid you know I gotta do
the other way yeah I always hit you the
other way man it's so good well yeah so
I'm gonna go uh I'm gonna go check out
some red wings ok you know there's a
boot I really like the beckman what
about some easy Spirits those ones those
high heels the girls could play
basketball in yeah and then I've been
wearing vans like crazy which are really
good but still feel like I'm kind of on
the concrete vans I would say are like
half a step up from converse yeah I'm
like yeah what your head Chuck Taylors I
can't wear at all yeah I'm on the
[ __ ] Sun the cement I wasn't going to
Adam at the story where's Chuck Taylors
antennas on my books who I go dude you
just standing on concrete on those you
know which is like crazy please get the
Chuck tues like there's no no shame and
getting the new chucks no Joe and tears
yeah treat your feet well yeah you have
your feet you know what like whether
it's on you my feet will hurt yeah my
neck will hurt my my what else sometimes
my hands yeah I'll be sleeping on my
hands with some I wake up I oh [ __ ]
everything hurts yeah I have its left
ankle left knee right knee also but like
the mains are left ankle left me then I
have what is it called oh god it's like
basically inflammation and kind of like
the connective tissue in my sternum
Castro costochondritis and like that so
that gets him flamed and hurts bad and
then I have poor circulation in my hands
yeah so I was the guy I worked in a law
firm I was the only dude that had a
space heater under his death a lot of
women would because I women's by
temperature some blow or whatever but I
was like where did you guys get that
from like I put in the order and had
like my little space heater cuz I sit
and type my hands would just lock up on
me and it hasn't gotten better and it's
only I'm gonna be the old dude you know
this dude you see they're like wearing
gloves in the summer yeah like paying
like to get their [ __ ] coupons out
yeah gonna be this guy Wow well here's
another thing too if I get into a car
yeah I feel like I'm gonna need to rent
a few uh to figure out make sure the
seed isn't [ __ ] me like that Subaru
had great see ya oh man it was killer I
drove to San Fran San Jose and it was
awesome you know but uh yeah the new
Prius seems to have some great seats and
i'm looking at prius because it's 50 but
we wrote in yours for thirty dollars to
Arizona yeah it's not bad but as also
again I don't have money but I was
looking at the Porsche Cayman Miami blue
huh for with the 17 miles to the gallon
uh-huh I can't get that cuz the payment
and insurance is the price of rent you
only live once but goddamn that cars
grow it's incredible if I was making
some money I'd own that car okay that
would be it I gotta give a [ __ ] that's
why I brought my first purchase would it
be a car my first purchase would be a
garage oh yeah then Phil oh yeah with
car you know what I mean like my list is
67 fastback Mustang 68 Camaro maybe I
think is when they tweaked it a little
bit I just loved 74 carrera it also like
a weird year but I kind of love them I
probably have what was it the 2012
corvette zo6 so I everyone like two
bodies ago gray could just throttle you
just like it's your banger supercar yeah
I mean yeah yeah the list goes on and on
and if I had a limited money they're
definitely be an e-type in there yeah I
just don't I mean about 90 like what I
didn't say that new Porshe they are you
know the white one with the red stripes
yeah that's it ya know in the car people
get scared that guy's badass that's his
rue de lis driver right those cars are
going four million dollars on eBay
luckily only made like what 50 / the
[ __ ] it was yeah ah a million dollars i
need that beautiful I saw a car
yesterday put a bit in come in right I'm
a million dollars that's a dumb move
and I would buy vintage ones way before
that one well that's there was an
article I think I said it to you like
the worst thing that Porsche is doing is
not making enough of their cars like
rock artifact like yes collector stuff
is a thing yeah but like this shouldn't
be that yeah this should be the car that
anyone that has whatever it normally
costs to 80 or 320 let them buy this
[ __ ] car it's crazy because you're
driving sales and then they can't get it
and that's a Harley thing would always
do that too they would release a certain
bike and then it wouldn't be you one in
each place mentality is well it drives
people into the store and then when it's
not there they'll just buy something
else that's how it used to be when
people didn't have the internet or any
search but now they're like well I'm
just going to go home and find this one
somewhere you heard I mean that's what I
did and that [ __ ] Porsche is
unbelievable but I would just buy like
sixty seven eight nine all those right
now and just watch your money go through
the roof like like [ __ ] man you know
all these guys are like let's see like
Jay Leno yeah I don't even know uh you
know if he passes away that collection
is a gazillion dollars young does he
have kids or like he does I've no idea
he has no kids or anything i J I'm
available yeah AJ Joe had yesterday a
four million dollar Ferrari crazy 66 it
was this f12 like special when this guy
was on and you guys can watch it I
tweeted it four million bucks it is the
sexiest carve ever sin is good six
carburetors it was the first one with
all independent suspension and disparate
down wood steering wheel kind of the hot
dog from yeah yeah looks like a mini
that yeah you know Oh God Oh million
guys for honey it's so funny because the
magnum p.i one yeah you could get that
even six years ago maybe eight years ago
I was looking on ebay you could get him
for 25,000 yeah those are a hundred
thousand I've come back up oh yeah
because people
can't afford the other Ferrari so now
these go up and now the people that grew
up wanting that Ferrari can own that
Ferrari so the you know it's like that's
there a nostalgic but every I had a
friend I went to law school with this
girl and we were came good friends and
her husband was a program or software
engineer programmer he kind of didn't
like his jobs we got out of his job and
now he does rare I think i mighta said
she was linked like exotic cars a lot of
Ferraris Iran oh yeah I remember
occurring or whatever so was a crazy
meeting of the world where I saw him
post on Facebook he's like oh here's
this thing you know you guys might have
seen me on and he was on an episode of
what's my car worth that Josh Nasar
house oh yeah here's like my buddy from
law school on this TV show with my
friend from comedy driving around one of
his awesome like rare Ferraris that they
take to an auction block I was like oh
that's a cool meeting of the world and
also [ __ ] Josh for getting to drive that
Ferrari they're gonna get me on that
[ __ ] snowman I want to get on one of
those shows just so I can drive that
[ __ ] man right yeah he just gets to hang
out with them and like kick the tires
and be the host yeah I thinks it's him
you know what I saw volkswagen had this
um gun I would get this car in a minute
they have a UH protocol one of those
called the concept concept of the
minibus yes I saw that CES did you see
that for I mean I want it looks just
like a 60s bug but more shorter and more
so like stout watch yeah squash I'm kind
of muscley looking I would buy that car
tomorrow I have been day I feel like VW
knows there's an interest there must not
be a big enough one cuz I feel like
every two to three years they tease a
new microbus right you know always like
make it I will and this one was like all
electric like I'll do the show car right
that is such an awesome design make one
of those that is slightly reliable and
gets decent mpgs oh it's my next [ __ ]
car I will go get by by Prius ya lo
microbus how [ __ ] cool it look it had
the windows and it was just like it add
the logo on the front like
the old hippie but I just get that slap
some deadhead stickers on it get a
French Bulldog cruise around and tour
comedy in that thing I put a 42 inch TV
in the back yeah heads a pinch the bench
see there yeah just drive around go
wherever do anything go to the beach put
a rack on the roof [ __ ] that thing is
killer man I wanted to fender 90 of
course but those things are 90 grand
yeah and that's because they got they
got another bump this year I think we
talked about on the show because the
last one is officially done it's done
again it was like four years ago you I
tried to get my wife to bylo they're not
the most reliable cars yeah techie the
effects yeah I easy fixed octave dude
about they're also kind of rough i was
telling a super up yes sir i think i
would get ago i'm [ __ ] her like you
know like the motorcycle just like oh I
shouldn't have got this i mighta Buick I
like the Jeep yeah the willies limited
edition right now that's cool but they
have [ __ ] gasps mall no I can't believe
that jeeps are still that yeah poor in
terms of gas mine I'm there you know
right after the Subaru I'm like
definitely going to ask my lights you
know that thing was a guzzler yeah well
you also wrote it pretty hard is the
hard part about those cars like my
Porsche when I'm a Porsche I think it
you know could get up to 28 or 30 yeah
but you're not you know when you don't
go out a second gear you're not getting
ain't no [ __ ] way when you're in a
WRX man that's like this is turn 30 like
watch this will hit at 80 yeah Oh will
draw your power band doesn't peak until
6700 RPG rpms you like you're not you're
not [ __ ] maxing out your FDD yeah
also i'm thinking like well what have i
got a car but i want to want to move to
New York yeah that I mean and then I
gotta sell the car I don't know I'm
[ __ ] a midlife crisis yeah mid mid
pain crisis well if you moved to New
York open a record shop in your place
here to sell your records oh yeah I
could be [ __ ] here man the owner of my
building died two weeks ago Oh No so I
go from not moving for 13 years yeah
into the new
and I and I was doing a bit about it for
a little bit and people it was almost
too dark but when I was looking for an
apartment I said I basically got I look
for the next place I'm gonna dye it yeah
you know what I mean because I don't
plan on moving and most people die
around 55-60 now yeah and that burn it
up hahaha sounds like a right I guess
I'll die in the valley yeah we gotta
meet a two-bedroom [ __ ] cheese story
what's the access for paramedics to get
in here and get a body bag out of here
where duh so two weeks ago and this is a
new thing about hunting apartments do
you have to ask now how old the owners
are I had no idea sign a lease owners 91
had no idea dies two Saturdays ago old
lady and immediately the family gets the
building it's on the [ __ ] two days
later it's on the for sale because they
don't want to manage it that's when I
know but salad get the money for the
money exactly so now it's it's it's down
to [ __ ] this again one owners
interested says oh the tenants can stay
yeah another owner not on a potential
buyer is interested he wants to tear it
down make it a five-story condos cuz its
zone for that they're right building
next to me is five stories you can go up
five stories and have 80 apartments
instead of six get everybody out that
might be there in the rent control
because they're making improvement to
the neighborhood yep I got it no they
got to pay you leave oh they do so yet
but this time I'm like when I got a
[ __ ] move again after one year I'm
just I just settled in there put a
[ __ ] floors in you know and and i'm
so glad i didn't paint it and get an AC
upstairs I don't know what's going on
yeah let's suck so if I have to move
this time do I take the money and run to
New York and rock it for a year out
there you know what I don't know I keep
throwing it out there if you're new york
listener and you gotta
bedroom I can rent out or something just
to see if I'd like it yeah hit me up man
but I don't know I'm just in that fit I
just love doing comedy so much huh and
we can we go through this every year you
and I might just get rid of everything
yeah have nothing well I mean I'd hate
to see you go but like you know I don't
know the politics of it but like if you
go to New York that's where serious is
yeah you just show up on their [ __ ]
door and there's no reason that you
shouldn't have no offense all things
company this is great yeah like there's
no reason that you shouldn't be like in
the studio next to Howard ya doing your
own [ __ ] show my friends are all
doing them right I get norton florentine
Eddie trunk and they're all there yeah
yeah they all got shows and make sure is
that serious office here in Thousand
Oaks but I think I one in hollywood to
be kind of uh I've been there before uh
it's but it's no we're not the mother is
not like the New York one thing is sick
but I mean you know the ultimate goal is
to have your podcast be huge where you
don't work for serious right you gets
you know that's my [ __ ] dream to be
able to do this show just anywhere yeah
I live in New York for six months like I
do the show here then I live in LA for
six months whatever the real goal of
doing the [ __ ] show is getting butts
in the seats and as I saw Sunday and
salt lake I don't know we'll see how it
works in Arizona coming up again last
time we were in Arizona it was pretty
good we got uh but this uh Utah gig was
fantastic and tons of people from the
podcast listen there's this girl cheese
maybe on a Japanese uh chiney one of the
two uh but she was like oh I love Quincy
Stone Age I i hear podcast i come to
show that's awesome and i'm doing her
voice like a dude and feel bad but she
was huge fan of queens of the stone age
now she's a big fan of the show yeah
that's incredible and she came you're
right you know and love the show and
then there was the two dudes that drove
from Utah to Denver last year to see me
no they came
its friends and then marry Stephen scale
she flew out there was all these people
there and it feels good you know feels
good to get the shell keep going kill
her guests are happening yeah yeah no
it's awesome but you know who knows if
those are just things that get your way
about doing comedy your mind gets
scrambled you like I got to just be
grounded to keep writing and performing
yeah you know what's the thing that gets
in the way of comedy the most is life
and the other things you need to do in
order to do comedy yeah I come the same
way like my video game fans are
incredible like you know my video game
podcast we were an entertainment weekly
last year well next to cereal and stuff
like that right it's incredibly pursue /
supportive oftentimes video game online
fans can it can be a toxic community
yeah but like our community that we've
built is awesome and supportive there's
always a couple of people at every show
I do and so I'm like I need to I need to
lean into this more yeah but then it's
like we're now spending all of my time
playing games or making vlogs or
whatever i'm gonna do this and I can put
I can set up lights here in my office
and I can just film here and then play
here and then do this and then do that
and then it's okay so Monday's vlog day
Tuesday land it wednesday i'll be
playing a live stream then thurs if it
is and then i can sell out shows them on
the road they haven't done any [ __ ]
comedy yeah to go on the road yeah what
that's the thing you get out on the road
and then you're not good because you
spend all the time and you see that no
offense anyone it does this but some of
these influence or stars yeah great
other content and then clubs or whatever
didn't use it don't think past that one
show or like oh you can sell it now and
then bring out Bo Susie's sin and then
you both sucks cuz both Susie said
doesn't do comedy like posting on it
makes awesome blog even me like I get
it's weird you got to figure out a
balance yeah yeah okay [ __ ] podcast
podcast is that it's going great i got
guests okay i got ten guests coming up
they're all [ __ ] good okay i got it
edit man yeah sundays are all [ __ ]
day with headphones on that's my monday
going through editing the podcast get
the intro going yeah put the you know
put the intro on
and get the photo upload the [ __ ] mix
it up load the podcast then tweet all
about it it's a good six to seven hours
yeah because I have to re listen to the
show to remember what we're talking
about stuff because we Bank the episode
right you know so it's all day then the
next day you know all right I gotta do a
podcast to air by the time I gonna do
comedy get a ton a day and a half and
I'm like yeah you know so i gotta stay
on the comedy and the podcasting equal
yeah now to [ __ ] its then you got to
work out gotta work out and then got a
[ __ ] ya figure out where I'm gonna
make some money this is money it's just
like okay I guess all ebay this not
these nine thanks yeah I got a shitload
of stuff on ebay right now and nothing
selman huh I was talking to some guy
some serious money people and they're
like yeah it's [ __ ] it's bad out
there huh like everybody's just ignoring
it you know yeah but uh you know I see a
long talk in the car industry i was just
reading this thing about how the prius
is dead huh cuz every big sold so many
pre system and they don't die or
anything everybody has a Prius and
toyota doesn't really have any other
models that are just going out the door
cuz they're all gas guzzlers i looked at
a forerunner today yeah 17 miles to the
gallon who's gonna buy that you know
when you can buy like a cross track from
subaru that's 34 miles to the gallon but
my point is toyota they're offering zero
financing and two grand to get a [ __ ]
thing the motorcycle industry keep
hearing about how great Indians doing
and yeah and tecate yeah and they're up
yeah but you know the other guys are
down everybody else is done and then
that bill it's just rotates it easy to
go up when you've been down for five
years go ahead and the other guys oh
yeah
new guy on the block I come in an Indian
you know but its ass his growing
motorcycle k every last 10 years spoiler
we didn't exist 11 years ago I've been
the bogus house market again you know
these houses are 151 I looked at some
houses I just look at houses every day I
always got a realtor the sentiment stuff
every day cuz I was acting now cuz you
know when I get famous and really ready
you know I gotta be ready ready I gotta
I mean I'm about to be rich you know
yeah just [ __ ] booming with cash
[ __ ] pie this studio full of cash
yeah yeah I want to be I want to be
ready yeah two or three beach um but uh
so I'm looking and you know uh after 06
the market [ __ ] blew up you know you
can get a killer house in the Hollywood
Hills for a million bucks ok I mean
killer now there's these shitty homes
all over the Hollywood Hills that are
next to the good ones like you got the
killer classic Spanish mansion and then
you'll have this shitty like three
bedroom weird 50s looking house hell
they're trying to get a meal for that
yeah and you're like dude that's a
teardown yeah yeah I mean that's not a
mill house that's a four hundred
thousand dollar home right you're buying
the property cuz no one's gonna live in
it yeah and then you know it all good
stand or getting old again rien enemy
they're like well you know how could you
pay for that for the next 20 30 years
you're just planning on work and I guess
yeah who wants to [ __ ] work when
they're 70 for real my dad you work at
something you enjoy let's say guy comedy
[ __ ] y'all are doing radio yeah but I'm
talking a straight-up grind wake up at
five shower and go drive to your job
that you can't stand just to pay for
your bills right it's [ __ ] rough I
know yeah let's get out of here well not
know me when you're old hey 35 when I
was 35 nothing [ __ ] hurt yeah I sound
like an old going forward to my 50s then
[ __ ] you I sound like an old guy right
when I was
35 head I did eight balls by the way
nothing hurt yeah alright alright guys
thanks make sure you subscribe and and
lube a review on iTunes and also check
me out on Joey Diaz podcast today I was
a guest last night excellent episode
very very insane episode last night our
boy Lee went went all in and check that
out and Oh Arizona I'll see you august
31st through September fourth at the
house comedy and what do you got I don't
know I'm not prepared for their Oh video
game stuff go to my twitch which is
twitch TV / Christian spicer and YouTube
which is Christian Spicer 713 thanks for
tuning in guys we'll see you next week
Oh mom